Okay, welcome back to the screen. What
we're actually going to do here is have a
recap of the important stuff that we've
learned so far throughout the video
series. And I think it's a good time to do
this, simply because you've seen a lot of
information up to this point.
And I think it's just a good idea now to
just outline and formalize all of the
important things that we've learned up to
this point.
And really the important stuff that we've
learned so far can be broken down into
three areas.
And that's really the approach that we're
taking or seeking to take, the investment
or trading process that we're using,
and the principles that underpin both our
approach and our investment and trading
process.
So let's start with our approach that
we're seeking to take.
Now going right back to the beginning of
the video series, we realized our
objective as retail traders was to attempt
to emulate the approach of successful
professional traders.
So we can be consistently profitable over
time.
And we realize given our objectives as in
using our own money to trade the financial
markets and make money using that money
consistently.
We realize given that objective and our
analysis of the professional trading world
that the objective is most closely aligned
to the objectives of a successful
professional hedge fund manager.
So the approach that we're taking is
really to try and emulate the hedge fund
manager, the successful professional hedge
fund manager.
And what we did was before we moved into
looking at successful hedge fund manager
approaches, we first laid the foundation
in terms of understanding what the
limiting factors are that retail traders
impose on themselves, which leads them to
consistently lose money.
And what we realized was that the main
reason why the majority of retail traders
are not successful and why they
consistently lose money is because they
quite literally take the opposite approach
to professional traders.
And this was broken down into four areas.
So not having an awareness of the conflict
of interest, thinking that trading is for
income, being seduced into using lots of
tools and thinking that all the answers
lie within the tools and the trading
platform.
And also suffering from information
overload and a misuse of unimportant
information.
So by understanding the limiting factors,
we managed to set ourselves a foundation
that leads on to many principles that
professional traders use in order to take
the correct approach.
So by laying this foundation, we can then
understand why professional traders and
hedge fund managers do the things that
they do in terms of the approach that they
take and the investment process or trading
processes that they take.
And really, the investment or trading
process that we looked at was a template,
a template that pretty much all
professional traders and successful hedge
fund managers use as their investment or
trading process.
There'll be many variations of this, but
essentially this framework provides you
with a skeleton, a template that can be
used throughout your lifetime to be
consistently profitable and emulate
successful traders.
And in terms of the process, it's broken
down into four areas.
So firstly, idea generation, secondly,
gatekeeping, third, having discipline or
risk management, and then fourth,
self-awareness.
And what we've done so far up to this
point is we've been through the first
stage of idea generation.
So we've formalized our worldview.
Now, when we look throughout the
investment or trading process that
professionals use, we can plug in to the
process at each stage anything that we
want in terms of our own expertise, but we
just make sure that we plug it into the
right area.
This is the process that professional
traders use, this is the framework that is
utilized to ensure consistent
profitability and to grow capital over
time.
So we therefore use this process and we
can plug into the four areas any areas of
expertise that we have, but we just have
to make sure we plug them into the right
areas of the process.
We also looked at volatility and we'll
discuss this in a second, but volatility,
we realized quite quickly that volatility
equals opportunities and opportunities are
everything for a trader, which means
volatility becomes everything for a
trader.
So let's move on to the principles, the
important stuff that we've really learned
up to this point.
Well, the most important thing that we've
learned so far once we actually identified
the limiting factors was that actually all
professional traders and hedge fund
managers have a very rock solid investment
and trading process like the wish
framework and they formalize their
investment or trading process in a very
similar way to it.
And we also looked at the principle of
trade ideas and how they are actually
generated.
And trade ideas are generated really by
utilizing top-down analysis so we can
formalize our worldview and that's taking
the macroeconomic approach and getting the
big picture in context.
And we then move on to formalizing our
industry and stock views in the stock
market, utilizing bottom-up analysis,
therefore microeconomic analysis.
And we're going to be looking at that in
upcoming videos, but this is how trade
ideas are generated by professionals.
Trade ideas are generated by professionals
by utilizing a mix of top-down and
bottom-up macro and micro analysis.
And macro formalizes our view or our views
on equities, so indices, equities at the
index level, currencies, commodities and
bonds.
Going back to volatility, we realize very
quickly that all traders are slaves to
volatility and professional traders
actually don't take one approach.
They take multiple approaches and they
transition between approaches dependent on
volatility in the market.
So traders are slaves to the market and
slaves to volatility.
They transition between portfolio manager
and short-term day trader dependent on
what the market allows them to do.
These are very, very important principles
and they need to be formalized at this
point.
Now, moving on to other principles that
we've come across, what we've realized is
that traders, we have to be self-starters.
We seek out our own information and we
don't rely on others to provide the
information for us.
We definitely don't trade for income.
We seek to grow our trading accounts as
large as we can over our lifetime.
And we try to make money with no
resources.
We utilize the publicly available
information, interpret it correctly and
turn it into real hard dollars through a
professional investment process
so that we can make money and rely on
ourselves to make money, not relying on
other people.
And we're taking the minority of
information that's available to us in the
world, the information that's relevant,
we're using this information really to cut
out the noise in the market.
So the vast majority, the 97% of noise
that we come across every day that isn't
actually going to make us money.
And this is a principle that I introduce
you to very briefly, i.e. seeking to do
the least amount of work possible for the
highest amount of return with the least
amount of risk.
This is a very important principle and
it's going to become more clear why this
is important as we move into the next
stage of the video series.
And we're also seeking here as traders not
to work hard, we're looking to work smart.
We've got 42,000 assets in the world,
therefore we've got endless opportunities
to make money.
And we work smart to identify these ideas
and the ideas that are going to most
likely make us money.
So with 42,000 assets in the world, we
have to work smart.
If we worked hard and tried to analyze
every single one, we'd end up getting
nowhere.
So we have to work smart and have a
professional investment and trading
process and emulate the smart hedge fund
managers.
And we attempt with these 42,000 assets to
spoil ourselves with ideas.
And this is a very important principle and
it's going to become more clear as we go
through the video series.
We spoil ourselves with ideas and we know
that ideas are just ideas and not yet
trades.
We definitely do not fall in love with our
ideas.
So go through these principles again.
Go through the approach again.
Make sure you understand the investment
and trading process and how things are
done in the professional world of trading.
Once you start really understanding that
stuff, then you stand a very, very good
chance of being consistently profitable.
Now we're going to move on now from our
leading indicators and we're going to move
on to the industry level and the stock
level within the stock market.
I shall see you in the next video on the
other side.